well here it is this might be the most
controversial and the most hated chapter
in the history of mha one of the most
important battles of the final war Arc
just came to an end and a lot of people
are mad about how it all went down this
week my hero Academia straight up broke
the internet and not in a good way
multiple factions of the fandom are
complaining about different things mha
haters are clowning on the series so
let's break it all down and see what all
the fuss is about you guys know how this
works if you enjoy my mha videos you
want to see more in the future leave a
quick like and comment right now for
that YouTube algorithm and if you watch
my videos but you haven't taken the time
to subscribe yet we are trying to hit 2
million subscribers here on the channel
so do it up right now that would be an
amazing achievement finally this video
will of course contain mha manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned in the previous
chapter we saw that toga's Quirk evolved
as she unlocked Dead Man's Legion while
Ocho squirk awakened in a spectacular
way allowing her to make everyone around
her float without even touching them
that was epic to see it's true but what
about ochiko's serious stab wound she
has already experienced some major blood
loss so isn't this severe injury taking
a toll on her body save that thought I
will get back to it soon but now let's
get to the chapter the new chapter
starts off with everyone on the
battlefield noticing that something is
very different with ochakos Quirk zero
gravity suddenly all of toga's clones
are floating even though ochako didn't
touch them meaning that ocho Canal
basically make an entire Army float up
into the air from long range this
completely changes zero gravity and its
potential on the battlefield I mean just
imagine what kind of damage ochako could
do with that power if she wasn't as
compassionate and heroic as she is like
she could literally pick up hundreds of
people at once and just drop them to
ground from a massive height taking them
all out instantly ochako would never do
something like that of course but if she
was willing to do that she could become
a straight up killing machine since toga
realizes that all her clones are
floating which makes them ineffective in
battle she tries to create a bunch of
new clones but then those new ones
immediately begin to float too this
means that ochakos Quirk is working
continuously so as soon as new clones
enter the area around ochako they too
begin to float immediately it's almost
like there's like a barrier or dare I
say domain around her this crazy turn of
events reminds Togo of the time that her
own Quirk awakened and she was able to
use ochakos Quirk to kill a bunch of the
meta Liberation Army members including
curious tiger and kamui woods are both
shocked to see what's happening tiger
says that nochiko's limit for how much
weight she can float up into the air is
supposed to be only like three tons and
yet there she is holding up an entire
Army of like hundreds of clones tiger
can't believe how how far Ocho and the
other UA students have come since last
year's training camp and yes this is a
good time to remind ourselves that time
passes a lot slower in the manga than it
does in the real world for them the
forest training camp Arc was just last
year we then finally get some
acknowledgment from Watcher code that
she is seriously injured and bleeding a
lot she thinks to herself that her body
temperature is plummeting because of the
blood loss but that's not important to
her now because she wants to touch the
sadness deep inside toga and make her
feel better and yes this is the only
mention we get about Chuckles injury in
the entire chapter toga is still
resisting and trying to get away from
ochako but ocheko remains attached to
her with the ropes that come out of her
wrists meanwhile a grotesque clump of
clones is floating all around them and
honestly in some panels these clumps of
twice clones looks like some kind of
creepy spaceship that is floating above
the battlefield fans of Science Fiction
will probably understand what I mean
anyway ocheko then tries to explain her
own backstory to toga in an attempt to
convince toga that she can in fact
understand where toga is coming from
ochiko says that her family is really
poor and over the years she became
accustomed to seeing her parents wearing
sad Expressions on their faces their
constant problems with money and
struggles to provide a good life for
ochako made him sad and exhausted and so
ochako decided to become a hero because
she wanted to make lots of money and
help her parents financially if her
parents didn't have to constantly worry
about their money problems they could be
happy and smile more often eventually
though ojiko realized that her parents
weren't the only ones who needed a hero
implying that even though she initially
wanted to become a hero in order to make
money for her parents she realized along
the way that there is more to being a
hero than making money being a true hero
means saving everyone not just her
parents and it even means saving someone
whom Society labels a villain someone
like toga ochako then says the words
that broke the internet net and sent the
mha Shipping Wars into nuclear territory
ochako says that she fell in love with
izuku midoriya well if this surprises
you then you definitely haven't been
watching the channel or paying attention
to manga but there you have it of course
ochako and Deku have romantic crushes on
each other and here ochako confirms it
publicly without any shadow of a doubt
ochako fell in love with Deku and sure
you can say some of what she loves about
Deku is his approach to heroics and his
selfless commitment to saving everyone
but trying to spin a clear statement
like this into her saying something like
oh she just admires deku's heroism and
she's not romantically interested in him
would be an absolutely massive stretch
now of course I know that half of mha
Twitter will be trying to make this
exact stretch anyway but it is what it
is welcome to the mha Shipping Wars
first time in the spirit of being like
Deku and trying to save everyone or says
that she wants to save toga that is who
she is and that is why she's here she
knows that to save toga she can't just
defeat her or send her to Tartarus she
has to talk to toga and the two of them
have to understand each other so this is
exactly what ultraco tries to do she
tells toga to tell her what she thought
back then and what she thinks right now
to tell her everything Toca doesn't want
to accept ochako's words but we see from
all the thoughts rushing through toga's
head that ochako's words are clearly
having an effect we then see a really
creepy and Powerful panel a monstrous
toga looms over a child ochako monster
toga is grinning and holding a knife
while little ochako stands there bravely
and offers her hand to toga presumably
offering toga her blood and that's when
toga
Stops With Tears In Her Eyes she
explains that it's easy for her to fall
in love animals villains Heroes boys
girls they all have such beautiful blood
flowing through their veins okay so this
once again backs up the idea that toga
operates on a different biological level
from other people she biologically
craves blood like you or I might crave
food or water and to her blood is
beautiful and so she seems to be
attracted to the beautiful blood of
others and not just men and women but
even animals it's almost like blood is
the main attraction Factor rather than
the person themselves although
ultimately I'm sure it's like a
combination of the two toga then says
that she was always told not to smile
because as you'll recall even her own
parents told her that her smile made her
look like a deviant and because of this
toga was always so jealous of other
people who could just smile and be
themselves freely toga then explains
that deck who looks just like a boy that
she really liked in the past a boy named
Saito and she really wanted to get
some of this boy's blood but she
couldn't bring herself to ask him for it
toga knew that if she asked the boy
would instantly think that she's like
some sort of inhuman monster and that
she was the opposite of cute toga loved
the league of villains because they let
her live her life the way she wanted to
the way that was natural to her and when
Deku and ochiko criticized the way she
lived her life this hurt her so deeply
because she cares about them in that
symbolic World in which ochako is
portrayed as a child tall guy is no
longer a monster and she becomes a child
too instead of stabbing ochako again
toga hugs her toga's inner monologue
then reveals that twice his blood is
almost running out and all the Clones
are about to disappear as the Clones
finally begin to disintegrate toga and
ochakor hugging while floating through
the air ochako says that even though
she'll never be able to replace the
league of villains for toga she just had
to tell toga that she has a beautiful
smile toga then smiles again tears
flowing from her eyes and wojako smiles
and says domain expansion okay I'm
kidding but imagine that what ochako
really says is the cutest girl in the
world with both of the girls crying and
smiling the twice clones vanish and this
chapter comes to an end and okay enough
delay let's get into all the controversy
the first big controversy is that this
major fight in the final Arc during a
major war seems to have essentially
ended through the power of friendship
Tolga didn't take out the heroes the
heroes didn't take out toga ochako used
taknojutsu combined with the power of
friendship to de-escalate the situation
and now that toga is out of time when it
comes to using Sad Man's parade the
battle is through the heroes have one I
can understand where this criticism is
coming from because yes we are in the
end game and the stakes should be higher
than ever before but at the same time as
soon as Ocho and toga became the main
focus of this fight we could have
guessed that something like this would
happen toga always desperately wanted to
be ochako and deku's friend but she felt
rejected by the two of them and ochak
always wants to resolve conflicts
without having to actually harm her
opponent so the idea of them talking
things out and getting to some sort of
understanding makes sense based on their
characters in this circumstance although
of course toga is a very unstable and
unpredictable character so things could
have taken a darker turn if horikoshi
wanted them to and this leads us into
the next controversy maybe ochako will
still suffer serious consequences as a
result of this fight due to that
stabbing injury she received to her
abdomen but the fact that this clearly
Serious injury was barely acknowledged
in the last two chapters is pretty
concerning I mean ochiko has been
fighting using martial arts and using
her Quirk and her Quirk awakened all
while seriously injured and losing a lot
of blood how could she just keep going
like she doesn't have a life-threatening
injury will the injury end up causing
any serious damage for her after the
fight or will it just be forgotten
making the injury itself nothing but a
cheap tactic used to increase tension I
do hope that horikoshi follows up on
this injury in some way because this
wasn't just a scratch this is a
life-threatening injury and it shouldn't
just be ignored or taken lightly finally
we have the dreaded shipping
controversies and these are worse that
all the others put together and
multiplied by 100 billion The mha
Shipping Wars have just reached the
stage of nuclear apocalypse this warm
and emotional moment between Ocho and
toga is being interpreted as a sign of
true friendship by some and as a sign of
romantic interest by others and the two
sides are of course not taking any
prisoners on social media oh and that
line about ochako falling in love with
Deku the izuocha faction is Riding High
on the back of that quote but the Deku X
literally everyone else insurgents are
digging in their heels for a long War of
Attrition this war will only end if Deku
X ochako finally becomes Canon at the
end of the story which I personally
think will happen but if it does happen
you better believe that the other
shipping factions will go berserk
everyone will be catching Strays and
unfortunately some of the most unhinged
shippers will likely attack horikoshi
personally because their head Cannon
didn't become actual Canon it seems
ridiculous to think that this is even a
possibility but it's happened before
just look at Tokyo ghoul and sadly I
think that it's bound to happen again
with mha the only way to avoid the
backlash is for horikoshi to make sure
that no ship ends up being confirmed in
the end but that will then still make
every hardcore shipper unhappy because
they need that validation from the
mangaka and so the cycle of toxicity
will continue even after the actual
series end and there you have it just a
few of the major controversies that have
Arisen out of one of the most
controversial chapters in the entire
series what do you guys think about all
of this you absolutely cannot forget to
leave your thoughts down in the comments
for this one if you're looking for more
epic mha content to watch check out my
full mha playlist Link in the
description and on screen if you guys
enjoy rmha videos you want to see more
in the future leave a quick like right
now and if you want to help us awaken
our anime YouTube Quirk by reaching 2
million subscribers hit that subscribe
button right now